vamos a la actualización de las noticias
económicas con Daniel hablándone y
Daniela lo estábamos esperando desde
esta mañana ya se conoció el dato de
inflación en Estados Unidos que fue
clave en estas elecciones de medio
término que acaban de pasar y se conoció
hace muy pocos minutos este índice de
precios al consumidor en octubre que fue
del 7,7% interanual muy por debajo de lo
que esperaba al mercado y también el
dato más alto desde febrero de
1982 baja cinco décimas con respecto al
8,2% que estaba en septiembre pasada
Porque es importante la inflación porque
es un indicador que la reserva Federal
siempre vigila muy de cerca para decidir
qué hacer con las tasas de interés Cómo
se han comportado históricamente esos
precios bueno los precios vienen
subiendo a su nivel más alto desde
febrero de 1982 hace 4 décadas la
inflación en ese momento era de poco más
del 7% y por eso han sido motivo de
disputa y un factor clave en las
elecciones de primer término con los
republicanos culpando a Joe biden de la
cifra tan alta por los millonarios
auxilios económicos y este defendiéndose
y entilgando el problema a la escasez de
suministroshimano de obra después de la
pandemia y también a la invasión de
Ucrania Si vemos este gráfico
notamos que cuando Donald Trump llegó a
la casa blanca La inflación era del 2,5%
interanual después llegó Joe biden
estaba más baja en 1,4% y ya el 8,2% de
septiembre Baja un poco al 7,7% y esto
le da un respiro de alguna manera la
economía de Estados Unidos hablaré de
este tema necesariamente nos lleva hacia
Wall Street Daniela que pasa con los
indicadores pues mire la bolsa de
Estados Unidos todavía no ha abierto lo
harán aproximadamente una hora pero sí
hubo un muy mal miércoles con Wall
Street de perdiendo más del 2% en sus
indicadores ahora se prepara entonces
para la apertura después de este dato de
inflación las bolsas de Europa también
se mueven en ese mismo orden Aunque más
disperso mientras se esperan también los
resultados de las elecciones de medio
término en Estados Unidos y le tengo una
noticia bursátil la firma de citas en
líneas Bum redujo sus proyecciones de
ingresos para este año dice que la mayor
inflación y el dólar cada vez más fuerte
está llevando a los usuarios a
ralentizar los servicios Premium a
medida que cortan gastos en servicios no
esenciales sus acciones caen en 19% en
las operaciones previas al mercado del
otro lado de la moneda está macho Group
que superó las estimaciones de ingresos
para este año por el auge que están
teniendo sus suscripciones a su
aplicación en línea tinder que es como
su aplicación insignia bueno y hablando
de Twitter de elon Moss que ya dio la
primera orden a sus empleados como dueño
Pues según la agencia especializada
bloomberg El Magnate envió el primer
correo electrónico personal a sus
trabajadores el miércoles en la noche y
en los está dice él preparando para
tiempos
difíciles que se avecinan les dio la
orden de prohibir el trabajo remoto A
menos que él mismo lo apruebe
personalmente esto lo hace el tiempo que
trata de tranquilizar a sus grandes
anunciantes en un Twitter reconoció que
podrían suceder algunas cosas tontas en
su camino para crear lo que él dice que
será una mejor y más segura experiencia
uno de esos movimientos a los que
seguramente hace referencia tiene que
ver con que Twitter comenzó a agregar
etiquetas grises a cuentas destacadas
incluidas marcas como coca-cola Nike o
Apple para indicar que son auténticas
Esto fue el miércoles pero unas horas
más tarde las quito qué firmas entre
tanto y en ese contexto en retirado o
suspendido su Pauta de Twitter Daniela
Pues esta incertidumbre que ha generado
la llegada de elon musk engrosa esa
lista con el pasar de los días hasta el
momento lo han hecho la compañía de
seguros allianz las automotrices
audífonos paguen y General Motors y
United Airlines y hasta la de alimentos
como la fabricante de los famosos chir o
el de las galletas oreo finalmente Los
japoneses le dicen adiós a un snacker de
más de un siglo estamos hablando de las
sakumas que son una especie de gotas
duras de fruta que han estado presentes
en la vida de Los japoneses por
generaciones enteras su fabricante de
sakuma seica con sede en Tokio dijo que
se fue a la quiebra como consecuencia
del aumento de los precios de las
materias primas y la energía así como la
escasez de mano de obra esta compañía
nació en 1908 y se hizo popular por
mantener la producción en medio de los
ataques aéreos en la Segunda Guerra
Mundial fueron tan icónicas estas gotas
que después aparecieron en una película
en la que una niña huérfana que lucha
por sobrevivir lleva consigo unas de
estas latas rojas como una de sus pocas
posesiones después de que su casa fuera
destruida ahora qué es lo que pasa en
Japón contrario a lo que sucede en otros
países en esta economía muchas empresas
han preferido no transferir Los
crecientes costos sus clientes por temor
a perderlos Daniela gracias a ustedes y
le invito para que se quede y vayamos a
directo París Así es diluiremos este
dato de inflación y se los tendremos
para mañana más completo